I don't want to embarrass you we've been
friends a long time and I I was blown
away by this movie and by your
performance in the movie thank you he's
fantastic
it's a serious dramatic role and we just
kill it thank you I appreciate you
texted me that you liked it the other
night
I stood you that I like that's what
those emojis were right there those hot
peppers yeah you know it's crazy you
know what's nice is that you're getting
a lot of recognition so many people are
writing that this is you know a
fantastic performance it's really
brilliant and you then I find out that
you got to go because the the meyerwitz
stores was plated at the Cannes Film
Fest and that you got to go with the
whole cast yes that must have blown you
away with awesome it was beautiful there
and it's free in France cand it's a
great Film Festival it's a wonderful
thing and we got invited to go there and
my wife was very excited so because she
kept saying oh my god we're gonna walk
up the red those red stairs some red
stairs there's iconic red stairs that
are carpeted that all every star in the
world has gone up those stairs and had a
picture taken by the French paparazzi so
she was excited about that my wife you
know and I was I didn't was unaware of
how great these stairs were and she and
she was like we have people do fall down
the stairs though you got to be careful
there cuz a heel of women and heels
sometimes will fall down the stairs and
I said well you're gonna be great and
she's like no no we have to practice so
we had like a month before we went in
every staircase we would practice and
she would hold onto my arm and be like
balancing or so we went on like the
old-style Stairmaster and we were
marching up she was really this nervous
about it she was terrified and so
anyways that we get there and it's as
beautiful stairs whatever and at French
paparazzi going bananas taking our
pictures and all that stuff and then
they invite the cast to go up the stairs
so the cast it's Dustin Hoffman and Ben
Stiller and and Emma Thompson and all
these great nice people so we walk
upstairs and we're waving to everybody
and there's a pin our picture and they
and then the head of the festival says
all right let's go inside and with a
French accent you know and then he said
let's go inside that is so lazy let's go
inside
with a French accent figured obvious oh
no I go inside so yes so anyways he says
go inside come on move it man I don't
know now he's a Rasta so yes so so we
say yes let's go inside then I look down
and see my wife is at the bottom of the
stairs so I was like oh my god I gotta
get to go down and get my wife so I tell
the head of the fest so I gotta get my
wife is a big deal for my wife we were
talking about going up the stairs and
the guy goes no no no I gotta go go
inside where the people are waiting this
is just for the sake of the story yeah
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
something like that
okay so then I looked down at my wife
and my wife's like waving me in and I
was like ah man we flew over here and
then she was so excited and then but
this guy really was a little mad at me
for thinking of going down and then I
hear Dustin goes go get your wife let
him get his wife and he stared down the
French guy he looked the minister he's
gonna get his wife right you are Dustin
man and so I wanna walk down the stairs
I got my wife and walking up and she was
like oh my god this is wonderful this is
like better than our honeymoon and then
I bet I you know I was like what do you
mean she goes you know you know what I
mean
[Laughter]
[Applause]
you